how do you under this pressure that
there's going to be a lot of
open source there's going to be a lot of
large language models
under this pressure
how do you continue prioritizing safety
versus uh I mean there's several
pressures so one of them is a market
driven pressure from other companies uh
Google Apple meta and smaller companies
how do you resist the pressure from that
or how do you navigate that pressure you
stick with what you believe in you stick
to your mission you know I'm sure people
will get ahead of us in all sorts of
ways and take shortcuts we're not going
to take
um and we just aren't going to do that
how do you I'll compete them
I think there's going to be many agis in
the world so we don't have to like out
compete everyone
we're going to contribute one
other people are going to contribute
some
I think up I think multiple agis in the
world with some differences in how
they're built and what they do and what
they're focused on I think that's good
um we have a very unusual structure so
we don't have this incentive to capture
unlimited value I worry about the people
who do but you know hopefully it's all
going to work out
but we're a weird organ we're good at
resisting product like we have been a
misunderstood and badly mocked orc for a
long time like when we started
and we like announced the org at the end
of 2015.
and said we're going to work on AGI like
people thought we were batshit insane
yeah you know like I I remember at the
time a eminent AI scientist at a
large industrial AI lab was like dming
individual reporters being like you know
these people aren't very good and it's
ridiculous to talk about egi and I can't
believe you're giving them time of day
and it's like that was the level of like
pettiness and Rancor in the field at a
new group of people saying we're going
to try to build AGI
so open AI Deep Mind was a small
collection of folks who are brave enough
to talk
about AGI
um in the face of mockery
we don't get mocked as much now
don't get mocked as much now